so was it like being a private
investigator the job is lonely you'll
sit up for hours watching the
[Music]
most sounds perfect I'll show you how to
run the business how to protect yourself
to
shoot but let me introduce you to Cassie
H hi she's a colleague of my friend Mel
telini I hereby appoint you Cassie halt
special investigator to the murder of a
brother
investigator whatever they were looking
for I'm guessing they didn't find
continue tracking the the money
Trail did it say anything about a hidden
room not supposed to be any hidden
rooms I've never seen anything like this
in my
life
[Music]
it's a murder that hardly ever happens
in our life the last time a private
investigator solve a murder was never
maybe not but I promise you that I
[Music]
will he was stabbed eight times in broad
daylight oh my God they sell them for
money when does this end the most look
like everyone else out there the
Predator strength is
camouflage I'm going to find
you don't let them most win no never
again
[Music]
obsessed with
Legacy
[Applause]
Cassie I'm going to kill
you
now